right uh let's bring in uh the science
Innovation and uh technology secretary
Michelle Donald is joining us um hello
Ms Donald just checking that you're not
a Manchester United fan this morning
good morning no I'm not okay okay good
for that are you a Liverpool fan
uh no no no
um I support my local teams but my
husband is very much uh leads supporter
oh dear I'm so sorry
um
talk to me about
um small boats uh pretty Patel promised
to tackle small boats in last year's
nationality and borders Bill and yet we
had a record 45 000 people more Crossing
uh the channel
um how is what uh Rishi sunak is
proposing going to be different
I think you've hit the nail on the head
those figures are staggering when you
compare where they were a few years ago
they were in their hundreds and it's
important that the government does
tackle this is why the Prime Minister
made it one of his top five priorities
it's why we've already taken action
we've got that record uh agreement with
the French government last year but
that's not enough that's why we're
bringing forward legislation the details
will be published this week and the
basic principle will be that if you
travel here illegally then it's not okay
to stay which I think is common sense
and the right approach
it's not illegal though is it to seek
Asylum it's illegal to smuggle people
into the UK shouldn't the Smugglers be
the ones that you're going for
he's got to be a proportionate and uh of
course we want to tackle criminal ground
gangs that's why we've acted
specifically to do that but we do have
to say it is not okay to travel here
illegally especially as we know many of
those people are traveling across many
safe countries to get here in the first
place and if they're traveling here
illegally they shouldn't be allowed to
stay we cannot take everybody as much as
we would love to we just cannot and we
have to have a system that works and
that's why we're bringing forward this
legislation is why the Prime Minister
has acted as I said we've got that
record deal with Brands we've done a
deal with Albania we've also invested in
more people to help us process and get
through the immigration backlog in
addition we're getting people out of
expensive hotels this is a government
that recognizes this is something that
people care deeply about and is acting
to address it but again Minister it's
not illegal to seek Asylum it's illegal
to smuggle people we were speaking to a
Smuggler not sure if you've seen our
exclusive report he tells us that most
of the Smugglers are based here in the
UK what can we do about it
but what we can do is bring forward the
legislation which is exactly what we are
doing
um I don't think it's right for people
to travel across many safe countries to
to get here and then choose to try and
uh seek Asylum via illegal roots that
that simply cannot be accepted why we're
bringing forward this legislation it's
not illegal but as I'm saying it is
people travel it is people trying to
secure Asylum via illegal means by
making Asylum it's not really many men
it's not a legal minister
across the channel that's what's illegal
so what we're saying okay is that there
are safe routes to get into this country
that is the correct process not to
travel here on small boats across the
channel after you've gone through many
safe countries and we do know that a lot
of the people on those boats are
actually economic migrants not genuine
Asylum cases and as a country we have to
have robust processes in place to deal
with that that's why this prime minister
has made it a priority is why we're
coming forward with legislation on top
of all the other things that we've done
on this agenda so that we can deliver
and make good on that pledge to the
British public
most of those that seek Asylum at least
two-thirds are allowed to stay in this
country anyway because they do receive
their status here in the United Kingdom
so what is it that we actually what is
it that you actually want to happen in
order are you saying that we should
change the rules so less than 66 can
stay
I think we've been quite clear that the
principle of the bill is if you travel
here via those means you will not be
allowed to stay now the details about
that 66 coming out over the coming days
and yet 66. the details will be coming
out in the coming days
well yeah it won't be that 66 because
logic dictates if we're saying that if
you you come here via those means you
can't stay then 66 of them won't be able
to stay because we're changing that
we're saying that's not okay okay as I
said pretty Patel did say that last year
and that didn't change much but let's
see what what's in the detail in the in
the coming days let me move on to sue
gray lots to talk to you about Sue gray
next potentially the next new chief of
staff for secure what questions do you
have about her appointment
well I think it's it's less about what I
have as questions and more about how the
process was followed there will be uh
people looking into this room the
cabinet office side and of course uh her
appointment would have to go through a
cobra which is the correct means for
them to assess uh the next stage in her
career having followed her Civil Service
career whether it was done throughout
the correct processes and whether she
can take up that new office so we need
to wait to find out some of those
details that come forward
but you acknowledge that she was
politically impartial when she did the
party gate report
well she was a leading civil servant who
um obviously swore and took to accepted
that the civil service code in which one
of those key requirements is
impartiality
and so you think that she was impartial
I think that uh that that was not the
question here the question is
new job offer coming back I think she
was impartial
I have no reason to believe she wasn't
gay she was a civil service a service
servant who signed up to the the civil
service code I think what people are
mainly concerned about here is what
process has taken place for her to
acquire this new job have talks taking
place when potentially um they shouldn't
have Etc these are the questions that
need to be looked at and answered and a
cobra need to be allowed to to do their
job and review this okay but she was
impartial when she did the report
um what about the former prime minister
nominating his dad for a Knighthood
that's surely nepotism is its finest
isn't it
okay I think that's speculation at this
stage obviously we've seen a report in
the media today but that's as much as we
know so who knows whether that's true or
not would you support it
wouldn't really be down to me um I don't
sign off those uh those those
appointments and those uh honorary
positions of course Prime Ministers and
previous Prime Ministers can then
nominate people for peerages for
different types of categories of honors
I understand and we have that system in
place which has worked successfully for
years but you'd be happy for him to be a
knight would you sorry okay I missed
that last question yeah I just said
would you be happy for meant to be a
knight of the realm
well let's wait and see before we start
speculating on ifs and maybe say okay
talk to me about the reason that you
joined us today
um growing the economy via Tech and
science how's that going to work
yeah so again the prime minister's made
uh many of his key five priorities based
on the economy cutting inflation getting
down the debt and uh growing the economy
which is fundamentally important to
improving people's lives getting the
better paid jobs and how do we do that
we do that by the true engines of growth
science and technology to spur on
Innovation what we've done today is
outline a strategic framework of how we
get there by 2030 that road map if you
like with action plans tagged onto it
but also we're acting in the here and
now too we've attributed 370 million
pounds to new initiatives including in
things like AI including in things like
money for Tech challenges so that we can
push through new technology and be at
the Forefront creating those better paid
jobs for British people here in the UK
okay it's great to talk to you um as
always look forward to seeing you in the
studio soon thanks very much